- All I've really learned from porn is
(pants) "Oh yeah."
(whipping)
(squeaking)
(woman moaning)
(slow funky music)
- The pizza man is not
always delivering pizza.
- Everyone's apartment is, like,
worth millions of dollars (laughs).
- I've learned that
porn is great to watch,
but it's also fantasy.
- A lesbian couple is just waiting
for someone with a dick to come around.
- Condoms just magically appear.
- There's a lot of different
positions you can get into.
- There is no mess with anal.
- People make weird noises in porn.
(pants)
- I'm talking about tennis, guys.
It's tennis.
It's safe for work.
- All women are a double Ds or Fs.
- Eight inches spans from
this big to this big.
- All women are instantly able to orgasm
at the drop of a hat.
- There's no need to get
consent in general usually.
That's what I've learned from porn.
- As long as, like, the women
are being treated respectfully, enjoy it.
(moans)
- Yeah, that's all I know
from porn, that's it.
- I've learned that moaning is an art form
from porn (laughs).
It really is, like, there
is a nice, like, sound
and, like, cadence to, like, the way
that a girl moans in porn.
(laughs) Oh wow, I've learned so much.
- It's here! It's here.
- [All] It's here! It's here! It's here.
- It's here.
- [All] It's here.
- Get it.
- There.
- There it is (laughs).
- I think they got it. Get it.
- Yeah.
- (girl in poncho) You get it.
It's here.
(digital music)
- Quick.